ρτα διαβάζεις τις εφιπεργιδες πάμε σε κάτι πιο ευχαριστο πως είται η κύρια παπάδο πουλος
αγιαγια πολύτούτα πολύ γιατί το ευχαριστο βεβαίως ήμουπροσπάθησα να είναι καλήγια για με τους δύο
πρώ τους είχα παρρεπερισότετετων ένα του κονσταντινο και μετά της μαγίας ήταν πριν την πιδρία
που είχαν γενηθεί και έτσι είχα περισσότερο χρόνο να σχολούμε μαζί τους μετά όταν ήευθα
οι πόλυποι βλέπροσπαθοπάντοτε να βλέπω όλα τα εγκόνια μου νατους να ξεω πως είναι αν
έχουν προβλήματα δεν έχουν προβλήματα ιδικά τώρα που αρχίζαν και οι έξι ιδή που δάζουν
τους παιγνω τηλέφωνο να δω πως πάνε και τώρα έχουμε και το μικό της αναστασίας
που είναι το παιχνίδι μας όλου δηναόλοι οή αφωσιωμένοι πάνωτου ρωτούν να μάθουν παιόσοι ήταν
ο πολύκαρπος γιορκάτης και ότα τους πάδοαι νομίζω όλοι πλαον οι μεγάλοι σίγουρα και θέουν
και γραυτηκαν και διβλία και έχουμε και τα ι δρήματα και το ίδργμα πολικά πως
διορκάτυις και το κντροτάσως παπαδόπουλος που έγραψε έκανεκαι τοαρουσίασε και το αρχίον του ταάσου βέβαια
τώθα πλέον μαθαίνουν και εγωτούν και πολύ φυσικό δηλαδή βλέπετε κάποιο αποτα εγκόνια σκεβάδο πουλο
να θέλει να σχορηθεί με την πολιτικ αούτε το σκευτικά μεττε το σκεφτικά αυτό το
πράμα δεν έχω ιδέα θα δούμε τη θα γίνει στο μέλον νομίζω πλέν τα παιδιά
ίσως τα εγκόνια να έχουν άλλες κατευθύσεις με τις νύφε η έσσας μια γράγά ν
χω και με της νύφεσμο και με το αμπγόυ έναγα προέχω αλλά μια χαγανέ